make america brouette guen ronde sa
grandeur à l'amérique c'est donc la
promesse de donald trump lors de son
élection 2016 alors qu'il remet son
mandat en jeu et que la campagne des
présidentielle bat son plein aux états
unis quel bilan économique tirées de ses
quatre années à la maison blanche
la méthode trump at elle porté ses
fruits at il été un ange ou un démon
pour l'économie on voit ça tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
à cames bienvenue à vous alors jacques
que reste-t-il de ces fameuses promesses
électorales de donald trump
alors évidemment la grande question
donald trump
il y a quatre ans s'était fait élire sur
un programme qui visait à revitaliser
l'économie des états unis
un programme qu'il avait déclinée
effectivement en économie intérieure
mais aussi en économie extérieure et en
particulier dans les relations entre les
etats-unis et la chine mais aussi les
états unis et l'allemagne
alors il faut tout de suite le dira
beaucoup de ses adversaires avec riz au
casque où il avait même dû certaines
aires pointé ce qu'ils appelaient
l'incompétence du candidat eh bien voilà
c'est pas exactement ce que l'on observe
quand on regarde les candidats et on
peut se poser une question qui fera
peut-être sourire c'est après tout et si
donald trump avait été tout simplement
un président normal
avant d'aller plus loin jacques ce qu'on
propose de voir ce qu'en pensent les
français que nous avons rencontré de la
politique économique de donald trump et
de son impact
si j'étais américain je suis plutôt
content parce que si je regarde les
résultats intérieur domestique
effectivement comme vous disiez le
chômage est au plus bas
la bourse est au plus haut de toute
façon cette politique l'américaine je
trouve très mauvaise elle rejette des
masses de gens qui sont en difficulté
quand vous regardez un petit peu la
situation des états unis est agressive
il est à la limite de conflits
internationaux qu'on n'avait pas jusqu'à
maintenant j'aimerais que la chine son
principal concurrent des états unis
ils essayent de rétablir la situation
économique de son pays il a tendu les
relations entre la france et certains
autres partenaires historiques la russie
les autres les pays aussi en
développement ajoute au solo pour être
bon pour l'europe dans la mesure où
l'amérique a fait de l'europe sa chasse
gardée
elle aurait pu être plus attentive aux
préoccupations européennes
il vient d'augmenter les droits sur les
importations d'airbus mais en fait ça va
ça va sanctionner les compagnies
américaines parce que du coup elles vont
se retrouver avec un surcoût pour nous
un ça marche moins mais après à nous
aussi en tant qu'européens en tant que
français de répondre à cette politique
là en si vous voulez en adoptant un peu
plus de protectionnisme oui je pense
qu'il va être réélu parce que tout le
monde est un peu aveugle pense que les
gens croient ce qu'il dit j'espère qu'il
soit pas réélu si des primaires
démocrates continuent à encenser bernie
sanders
il a une bonne chance de remplacer dès
les primaires démocrates mais absolument
aucune chance de remporter des élections
américaines au niveau national je pense
donc je pense qu'on va on va devoir
faire et composer avec donald trump
pendant quatre ans supplémentaires eu
votre réaction jacques alors on en
compte deux choses qui sont à la fois
contradictoires rien et en même temps
très logique
la première c'est évidemment des
réactions des français qui sont très
pris à rebrousse poil par la politique
commerciale de donald train mais il ya
quand même des gens qui dit oui mais
voilà il a apporté des résultats
pour les américains il ya une croissance
égale à moins de chômage alors jacques
où on est l'économie américaine alors
évidemment premier point c'est bien
entendu la croissance est de ce point de
vue là il faut dire que donald trump se
situe dans la continuité de ce qui avait
été fait dans les années de barack obama
voyez par exemple sur ce graphique on
voit que la croissance américaine elle a
été important elle était même plus
importante que la croissance allemande
plus importante que la croissance
japonaise
bref il y à bien une croissance et une
croissance qui t'amène à s'accélérer
on le voit en particulier si on regarde
les résultats qu'ils avaient été
obtenues par barack obama de 2012 à 2016
et ceux qui ont été obtenues par donald
trump de 2018 à 2019 en a ici incluent
deux
1020 même si il ne s'agit ici que de
prévisions et bien en réalité
donald trump est un peu mieux que son
prédécesseur de 24% en moyenne par an
contre 2 2% pour barack obama
alors mes jacques les etats-unis sont un
immense pays
comment cette croissance at elle été
distribués sur le territoire alors vous
avez tout à fait raison de poser cette
question parce que évidemment les états
unis pays de 330 millions d'habitants et
bien c'est évidemment énorme alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir que la
croissance est bien va concerner
essentiellement les états qui se situe
entre les deux coachs et les états du
middle west
et on va aller de la de l'alaska au
texas ce qui est intéressant
surprise surprise peut-être c'est que ce
n'est pas sans correspondre d'une
certaine manière à la carte des
résultats électoraux de 2016 et on voit
là aussi que c'était bien danser et à la
danse est compté là ont réalisé
puisqu'il s'agit d'une carte par compter
que donald trump avait fait ses
meilleurs résultats
et ça aussi c'est un point important
d'une certaine manière il a satisfait
ces électeurs alors la question est ce
que cette croissance at elle eu un
impact sur le taux de chômage
ah oui évidemment et alors là c'est
extrêmement important
les états unis avaient été sortis de la
crise avec un taux de chômage
particulièrement élevé et ce taux de
chômage n'a cessé de baisser alors il a
il a baissé d'un sous les années de
barack obama ça c'était tout à fait
évident et il a continué de baisser dans
les années
donald trump même s'ils baissent moins
vite et pour une raison très simple
c'est que là le taux commence à
s'approcher de cette limite dites
incompressibles ou en tous les cas de
chômage structurel que l'on peut situer
autour de 3 à 3 5% par an alors oui il y
a eu des des résultats tout à fait
évident du point de vue du chômage
mais là encore on va voir des
différences entre états en particulier
ce sont les états de l'asean ben c'est à
dire les états du sud de la côte est qui
était déjà traditionnellement des états
où la situation économique était
relativement bas
alors c'est par exemple la caroline du
sud la virginie l'alabama
on voit aussi un et atypique des grandes
plaines le dakota du nord est puis par
contre les états dont les résultats sont
plutôt mauvais on se situe autour de 4
3% de chômage
eh bien ça ce sont les états de la
pennsylvanie du mississippi de la
louisiane il ya aussi l'arizona ce qui
prouve que les résultats de ce mythe de
l'ouest ne sont pas uniformément bon non
plus alors jacques quel a été le rôle de
la politique économique donald trump est
il un président particulièrement
dépensiers
alors on encore si on compare avec ce
qu'avait fait barack obama mais il faut
toujours rappeler que barack obama avait
à gérer les conséquences de la crise aux
etats unis
et bien on se rend compte que donald
trump n'a pas été particulièrement
dépensiers allant voilà que si on
regarde l'évolution des dépenses et
l'évolution des recettes évidemment
barack obama a été très dépensier par
rapport au déficit budgétaire jusqu'en
2012 2013
après ça s'est resserré et évidemment
donald trump a redonné un petit peu de
déficit budgétaire mais bien moins
qu'obama au départ seulement il ya un
autre problème c'est la question de la
dette publique américaine
et là on voit que cette dette publique
elles avaient augmenté très fortement de
2010 à 2014 sous barack obama elle
s'était stabilisé à la fin de la période
de barack obama est au début de la
période de donald trump et l'a à nouveau
elle repart aujourd'hui les états unis
ont une dette publique d'environ 109 %
du pib et le solde extérieur alors car
le slogan mec america briguen impliqués
bien un effort pour rld a misé
redynamiser l'économie américaine face à
ses concurrentes chinoises et allemandes
ah oui tout à fait vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est bien sûr la question de la
politique extérieure d'une certaine
manière que l'on attendait en
particulier donald trump
alors on se rappelle sa politique des
tweets bon ce que l'on constate c'est
que là le déficit qui était important
sous barack obama mais qui avait tendu à
se réduire
dans la dernière année de barack obama
eh bien il est resté à peu près constant
voire il a même que recommencé à
augmenter en 2010 neuf donc de ce point
de vue là il n'y a pas de changements
importants apportés par donald trump
alors le tableau que vous dressez est
donc celui d'un bilan mitigé vous
écoutez bien mitigé n'importe quel
dirigeant d'un pays européens en
particulier les dirigeants français il
serait fou de joie d'avoir les mêmes
résultats vous vous rendez compte une
croissance moyenne de 2,4 pour cent
ça serait inespéré pour un pays comme la
france moi même pour un pays comme
l'allemagne
maintenant il est vrai que il faut
toujours comparer ses résultats aux
espérances que donald trump avait
provoqué en particulier justement avec
son slogan un mec américain great games
et par rapport à ses espérances
évidemment ces résultats même s'ils sont
bons peuvent paraître à certains un
petit peu décevant il y à gros à parier
que donald trump va dire justement à ces
futurs électeurs et bien redonner - un
mandat de quatre ans pour que je termine
le travail je finisse le job et que je
fasse ce à quoi je m'étais engagé merci
pour ces explications jacky comme
toujours donne à réfléchir merci à vous
et à très bientôt sur arte france